and i've been around her and she was  fantastic  and she led the country through some of  our greatest and darkest moments with  grace  decency and a genuine caring warmth i'm  you know stephanie five she's been with  me all my life and i feel very sad that  she won't be with me anymore but i'm  glad she's at peace i'm glad she's at  rest and she deserves it she's worked  bloody hard i send my love to her family  and her loved ones  and she will be missed but her spirit  leaves lives on and we celebrate her  life tonight with music okay  from my homeland with some very sad news  today the passing of queen elizabeth ii  please  join me in a round of applause for 70  years of service  thank you madison square  [Music]